here we've graphed the function y is
equal to the square root of x and we're
going to create a solid of revolution
but we're not going to do it by rotating
this around the X or the y axis instead
we're going to rotate it around another
somewhat arbitrary line and in this case
I will rotate it around the line y is
equal to one so let's say that this
right over here is the line y equals one
so this is what we're going to rotate it
around y equals one so the first thing
we want to do is visualize what we're
doing and we actually care about the
interval so let's say that the interval
is between this point right over here
where the two points intersect and let's
say between that and X is equal to four
so let's say that this right over here
so this is x equals four so it's going
to be just right over here so this is
the interval that we're rotating we're
going to rotate it around y equals one
not around the x axis so what would our
figure look like well we're going to
rotate it around we're going to rotate
it around like this I'm going to rotate
it around something like this and so
your figure is going to look I guess you
could call it it'll almost look like a
conehead if you view it on the side or
something like a bullet but not quite
looking like a bullet but it would look
it would be a shape that looks something
something like that so hopefully we can
visualize this we've done this several
times already trying attempting to
visualize these shapes but let's think
about how we could actually figure out
the volume of this solid of revolution
well let's just think about it disk by
disk so let's construct a disk right
over here let's construct a disk right
over here and we've done this many many
many times already where we essentially
want the volume of each of these disks
and then we're going to take this for
each of these X's in our interval and
then we're going to take the sum of the
volumes of all of the disks to find the
volume we're gonna stack them all up or
I guess put them next to each other in
this case and find the volume of our
entire figure and so to figure out the
volume of each disk we just have to
figure out the area of its face the area
of its face and I'll do that in purple
we just have to figure out the area of
the face and multiply it by the depth so
what's the area of this face well it's
going to be
I times the radius of the face squared
times the radius of the face squared now
what's the radius of the face here well
it's not just square root of x square
root of x would tell us the different
the distance between the x-axis and our
function it's now square root of x minus
1 this length this length right over
here this length right over your square
root of x minus 1 for any given X in our
interval so it's going to be equal to
square root of let me do that same
orange color just to make it clear where
I'm getting it from it's going to be
equal to square root of x minus 1 minus
1 it's essentially our function minus
what we are rotating around that gives
us the radius and so this will give us
the area of each of our faces and then
we just multiply that times the depth
the depth of course is DX we've done
that multiple times so times DX this is
the thing that we want to sum up this is
the thing that we want to sum up over
our interval and our interval let's see
this point right over here where the
square root of x is equal to 1 that's
just going to be x equals 1 this is just
x equals 1 over here and we said that we
would do this all the way until x equals
4 this was kind of our end of our
interval so this is until X is equal to
I'm going to be careful this is the x
axis right over here this is the x axis
right over here all the way until x
equals 4 so you get confused this is the
X X so we're going from x equals 1 to x
equals 4 and we're essentially taking
this area one way to think about it
between the our square root of x + 1 and
we're rotating it around 1 so we're
using these little disks right over here
so the intervals between 1 & 4 and so
this is going to give us the volume of
our solid of revolution and so now we
just have to evaluate this definite
integral so let's give a shot at it so
this is going to be equal to the
integral from from 1 to 4 1 to 4 and we
can factor out where we could put the
pie outside the integral sign and then
we can expand this out so
square root of x-squared now all we're
going to do is expand to this binomial
so square root of x minus 1 times square
root of x minus 1 square root of x times
square root of x is X square root of x
times negative 1 is negative square root
of x negative 1 times square root of x
is another is negative square root of x
and the negative 1 times negative 1 is
equal to positive 1 so this part right
over here will simplify to it'll
simplify to X minus 2 square roots of X
this is 2 minus 2 square roots of x
minus 2 square roots of X and then you
have plus 1 and then all of that times
DX so this is going to be equal to let's
put our PI out there the antiderivative
of this business so the antiderivative
of X is x squared over 2 the
antiderivative so minus 2 times the
antiderivative of square root of x well
square root of x is just X to the
one-half power so we increment the power
by 1 so it's going to be X to the 3
halves power times 2/3 so times 2/3 or
we could say it's going to be it's going
to be times 2/3 X to the 3 halves
let me make it clear this negative 2
this negative 2 right here is this
negative 2 and this expression right
over here
is the antiderivative of square root of
X and you can verify this if you take
the derivative of this 3 halves times
2/3 is 1 decrement the 3 halves you get
X to the 1/2 now let's take the
antiderivative of 1 well that's just
going to be equal to X and we're going
to evaluate this from 1 to 4 so we're in
the homestretch so this is going to be
equal to
it's going to be equal to PI times well
first let's do it at 4 see if 4 squared
I'll write it all out 4 squared over 2
minus what's 4 to the 3 well let me do
this part first so minus 4/3 4/3
and that was for to the three-halves so
4 to the 1/2 is 2 and then you raise
that to the third power you get 8 so
times 8 times 8 plus 4 and then you
subtract out all of this stuff evaluated
at 1 so 1 squared over 2 so that's just
going to be minus 1/2 and then we're
subtracting this now actually I want to
skip too many steps so let's do let's do
it's going to be it's going to be this
this is when we evaluated at 4 and then
we're going to subtract when we evaluate
this whole thing this whole thing at 1
so when we evaluated it at 1 we do this
in this green color or that's well
that's let me do it that's not the green
color I thought I was going to do so
when you evaluate it at 1 you get 1
squared over 2 which is 1/2 and then you
get 1 to the three-halves which is just
1 so this becomes minus 4/3 minus 4/3
and then you have plus 1 plus 1 and so
let's simplify this and I'll do it all
in the same color now this is going to
be equal to PI times well 4 squared over
2 that is 16 over 2 which is equal to 8
and then you have 4 times 8 which is 32
over 3 so minus 32 over 3 plus 4 and
then you have minus 1/2 we're just
distributing the negative plus 4/3 plus
4/3 and then you have minus 1 and now we
just have to add up a bunch of fractions
to simplify this thing so what do we get
this is going to be equal to PI times
see our least common multiple looks like
6 we're going to put everything over a
denominator of 6 everything over a
denominator of 6 and so 8 is the same
thing as 48 over 6 32 over 3 is the same
thing as 64 over 6 so minus 64 over 6 4
is the same thing as 24 over 6 1/2 is
the same thing as 3 over 6 so this is my
negative 3 over 6 the same thing as
negative 1/2 4/3 is the same thing as 8
over 6 8 over 6 and the negative
one is the same thing as negative six
over six a little bit of arithmetic here
and let's see what we get so if we take
if we take 48 and we subtract 64 from 48
we get negative 16 is that right yes we
get negative 16 and then if we add 24 to
negative 16 you get positive 8 positive
8 minus 3 is 5 5 plus 8 is 13 13 minus 6
is 7 so this whole numerator simplifies
to 7 so we get 7 PI over 6
as our volume and let me just verify
that right so this is going to be
negative 16 we get to positive 8
positive 8 plus positive 8 is 16 16
minus 9 is yes as it is indeed 7 so we
get 7 PI over 6 and we're done we
figured out our volume of this little
sideways cone looking thing